E aí
há cerca de setenta e cinco porcento do
nosso guarda-roupa não é utilizado meu
nome é João com uma gaia tem algumas
perguntas para te fazer você tem aquela
peça de roupa que está estacionada lá
que você nunca mais usou
o e aquelas que você ainda tem a
etiqueta lá presinha bem bonitinha como
se tiver dentro da loja e agora eu quero
te convidar
se calcula o valor que tá ali paradinho
durante a minha trajetória eu peguei
iniciei minha graduação em moda ela é eu
tiver acesso a várias informações
referentes a indústria E lá eu descobri
que a indústria ela sempre vai falar o
que compra compra compra ela sempre vai
te influenciar a consumir cada vez mais
a gente tem que começar a entender que
existe um consumo consciente são aquelas
compras que a gente tem um crivo maior
para pensar eu também fui uma dessas
pessoas então Não se culpe todo mundo já
comprou por impulso todo mundo já
consumiu uma peça que você e assim
acabou esquecendo a gente acaba se
tornando grandes acumuladores a gente
com muitas peças dentro do nosso
guarda-roupa parado
e a gente tem que entender que essas
peças em algum. Elas vão causar um
stress né gente porque a gente vai ficar
vendo vendo vendo já que não vai saturar
vai até um dia que vou chegar assim eu
não aguento mais é isso eu vou tirar do
meu guarda-roupa
então eu vim aqui vou dar algumas
Soluções
a primeira Ball começar a bordar sobre
consumo consciente Como que você chega
nesse patamar Primeiro vamos começar a
entender o nosso estilo
nosso estilo depois que a gente começa a
se descobrir e se não conseguir chegar
nesse ponto tá tudo bem existem
profissionais da moda para ajudar
daquela consultoria Maroto ali você
ficar bem eu demorei muito tempo para
conectar com meu estilo esses
profissionais ajudam a gente a se
encontrar e digamos assim ou só em blog
Pinterest Instagram sempre vão te ajudar
para você o norte ali em algum lugar
para nós inclusive vou já parou para
pensar no Impacto de consumir com
consciência tá por exemplo e isso ajuda
a gente a se vestir mais rápido do nosso
dia a dia porque o nosso guarda-roupa
acaba sendo muito mais funcional e a
gente acaba poupando o meio ambiente de
ter várias peças de roupa que a gente
não vai usar porque geralmente a gente
costuma descartar de maneira errada e o
terceiro o impacto financeiro imagina
ali você sei lá r$ 2000 no final do mês
para poder viajar imagina no final do
ano inclusive quando a gente pensa em
consumo consciente a gente cria esse
crivo maior para escolher as nossas
peças de roupa por exemplo quantas vezes
eu vou conseguir usar essa peça
ela é para alguma ocasião especial
oi e ela é fácil de combinar com as
peças que eu já tenho dentro do meu
guarda-roupa quando a gente tem mais pés
a gente acaba demorar um pouco mais para
se vestir isso acaba levando a gente
para
aquelas tipicas e na abri o guarda-roupa
cheio amontoado apolado e a gente eu não
tenho nada para você
E aí vamos começar a repensar um
pouquinho e eu que tudo isso tem a ver
com aquela parte de estilo que eu tava
falando disso pessoal vamos entender que
a partir do momento que você identifica
ele você começa a comprar o mesmo grupo
de peças sempre vai ser o mais do mesmo
só com um pouquinho diferente só que ele
vai ter certeza que você vai usar então
por exemplo
eu penso em você como o personagem
Você já imaginou assim você é
reconhecida a distância para as pessoas
que a gente não pensa assim personagem
de desenho novela filme todos eles usam
mesmo meio que uma roupinha ali sempre
igualzinha ou dentro do mesmo estilo
isso vai fazer com que você consuma
menos consuma com mais assertividade
agora voltando um pouquinho para os
impactos vamos falar com exceção da
verdade
a sustentabilidade ali ela é constituída
por três pilares o social o econômico eo
ambiental para que algo seja sustentável
esses três pilares precisam coexistir em
harmonia
e quando a gente fala sobre a moda a
gente tem que pensar assim Apesar dela
ser maravilhosa dela e também criativa a
gente acaba se deparando com a indústria
que mais polui no mundo a moda é
responsável por 10 por cento da emissão
total de gases de efeito estufa é
responsável também pela poluição de
vinte por cento de mares e oceanos sem
contar 12 de mão de obra abaixo de um
valor ele seria sustentável inclusive
mão de obra infantil e também
responsável por 10 por cento de um
montante de uma tonelada e cem mil
quilos são por buscar Station resíduos
sólidos como a gente pensa em consumo
consciente a gente acaba tendo um
reflexo na indústria toda vez que a
gente compra um produto de uma empresa a
gente basicamente tá falando para ela
olha para que o meu dinheiro eu tô
gostando cada vez mais para mim sempre
vai sair essa validação Econômica então
para a gente escolhe marcas que tenham
propósitos como a conservação de meio
ambiente com as marcas compram
matéria-prima com fonte de procedência e
empresas conseguem ter uma melhor
fiscalização dos terceirizados da pessoa
que fez o plantio e etc todos os
impactos vão acabar aí que auxiliam
Então como a gente tá me dispensando Não
personagem que é você se você pode
inclusive pegar ali dentro das peças do
seu guarda-roupa
separados que você mais usa só
personagem tá lindo elas olha para
aquelas Peças na hora de comprar procura
tentar ali comprar peças são parecidas
com aquele estilo porque você
visualizando a ele você consegue
procurar pranchas de inspiração então
Norte melhor para sua conta você
consegue ter um dia melhor de compras um
dia mais consciente
e esses impactos vão resultado e menos
poluição
impressas que você vai demorar muito
para se desfazer Então os vai conseguir
ter um uso muito melhor dela e vamos
pensar também então tá reaproveitar o
máximo existem peças de roupa que às
vezes a gente pode usar para um
artesanato fazer um paninho chão ou
venda em brechó trocar uma amiga ou com
amigo ou como amigo então existem
entidades aí posso lhe dar existem em
possibilitar para a gente dançar um
destinar um produto melhor seja no
descarte no reaproveitamento de
utilização no nosso site inclusive uma
tendência muito forte e quando a gente
pega uma pecinha a gente trança nela a
gente dá um ciclo novo ao invés de
cargos e Olá meu nome é João como h&m e
eu queria agradecer vocês